the finals mvp is lebron james
well you're stuck with him lebron
congratulations
you said the other day and i want to
read this to get it exactly right lakers
fans quote
don't give a damn about what you've done
before when you become a laker
you've got to do it with them as well
well you have done it lebron what does
it mean to you
means a lot it means a lot to represent
this franchise
um jeannie i told jeannie when i came
here that uh
i was gonna put this franchise back in
the position where it belongs
her late great father did it for so many
years and she just you know took it on
after that and
for me to be a part of such a historical
franchise is uh
it's an unbelievable feeling not only
for myself but for my teammates for the
organization for the coaches for the
trainers everybody that's here
um we just want our respect
rob wants his respect coach vogel wanted
his respect
our organization want their respect
laker nation won't they respect
and i want my damn respect too
well lebron i'm going to tell you four
finals mvps
are
extremely elite company and in year 17
as well you got a guy in your ear right
now
telling you're the greatest of all time
you're just a couple months shy of your
36th birthday
is this the longest crime in the history
of professional sports i don't know i'ma
let you guys talk about it
one thing i can do is commit to the game
i put myself and my body and my mind and
position to be
available to my teammates i've never
missed a playoff game in my career
and the best thing you can do for your
teammates to be available
and for me to be available to my
teammates and put into work
i just hope i make my guys proud and
that's all that mattered to me i made my
guys proud make the fan base proud my
family back home
i can't wait to get back home to them
akron ohio we did it again and uh
you know that's what it's all about you
have had an incredibly close partnership
with the guy over there to your left
what can you say about the way you two
work together
to get this trophy here tonight i mean
it's easy it's easy um i said it in the
pressure
before we have no ego
we want the best from each other every
single day both in
off the floor on and off the floor and i
know what it means to have seven years
when you feel like um that you can't get
over the hump
you know i had seven years my first
stint in cleveland i felt like i
couldn't get over the hump
i felt like i needed some help i feel
like i need someone to push me
and that's when i was able to go to
miami and get pushed by d wade and bosh
in that franchise
and so to be able to get him and we push
him
and let him know how great he is but
just making him see better basketball
and better to be a part of something
that's special
that's what it's all about so to be able
to put him where he is today
that means so much to me and the fact
that he trusts me
uh means even more you were very vocal
coming in here that you weren't just
trying to win a title in this bubble
but you wanted to be a real voice for
social change and what has been one of
the most turbulent years in american
history
when you look back about what the entire
nba brotherhood did
in this bubble what will you think of
it's been unbelievable
it's been unbelievable we didn't know it
was the unknown
but i think adam i think everybody from
the nba to mbpa
putting this thing together um you know
and us using our voices us using
being together you know you hear golden
state always use the phrase strength in
numbers
and that's exactly what it was while we
were here as a as the nba as the mbpa
all our players everybody had a voice on
what's going on in america
so um we know we want we all want to see
better days
um and when we leave here we got to
continue to push that continue to push
social injustice continue to push for
voter suppression continue to push
for police brutality continue to push
for everything that's the opposite of
love
and i think if we can continue to do
that all of us
america will be a much better place
which we all love this
this country lebron thank you so much
for pushing against
all of those things congratulations
thank you on that trophy in your hand
appreciate it and your fourth nba title
let's bring up anthony davis please